exposing the Sinister truth behind
ancient androgyny dating back to
Mesopotamia androgyny was more than just
a gender identity it was a symbol of
spiritual power and privilege the gala
Priests of Ishtar embodying both male
and female traits held sacred roles they
were revered but also feared for their
mystical abilities fast forward to the
notorious alist Crowley who embraced
these ancient ideas Crowley a
controversial occultist saw androgyny as
a path to divine power he believed it
could unlock hidden spiritual Realms
from Mesopotamia to Modern occult
practices the Allure of androgyny
persists it's not just a trend it's a
powerful symbol that has captivated
Minds for Millennia want to dive deeper
into these occult Mysteries check out
our full episode for the chilling
details until then stay curious and stay
cautious
[Music]